this video is sponsored by Knights
Chronicle yes nice Chronicle were nice
enough to come back to sponsor us again
today and in case you missed it last
time nice Chronicle is an anime inspired
RPG available on the iOS and Android the
combat system here is turn-based and as
you can see it not only looks great but
has lots of depth in it too that's
because you have over a hundred
different characters to choose from with
their own unique abilities and passives
to include in your party which you can
duke it out in PvP or PvE this includes
a lot of top-tier y foods and husbando
is voiced by many famous anime voice
actors you are likely to recognize since
I last talked about it new characters
have already been added in Janus and ver
dandy along with new costumes as the
game is constantly being updated if this
sounds like a cup of tea links in the
description below to download it on
either iOS or Android and with that said
we can get on to the topic of this video
and it's a hot one warning warning hot
take incoming careful don't burn your
time now it's a hot boy coming through
just make sure you don't drop your job a
black clover is actually underrated
almost one year ago now black clover
released to a post hero ARCA season 2
hyped anime community only to get
absolutely destroyed by fandom hungry
for blood collectively taking a dump on
a 15 year old boy who had the voice of a
thousand crying babies being put for a
cheese grater helped by some [ __ ]
youtubers and you know what's rightly so
the beginning of this anime was
absolutely awful
but now 50 episodes later and nearly 200
chapters into the manga with the anime
confirming to be continuing past its
original run black clover still to this
day has a horrible rep thanks to the
atrocious start and scream means that
someone helped perpetuate so today I
thought I'd revisit black clover because
honestly being caught up to the manga
and anime I don't think it deserves all
the [ __ ] it gets so I'm going to do
something I never thought I'd do a year
ago I'm going to defend black clover
let me get this right off the bat right
now black clover is not for everyone I'm
not here to convince you that black
clover is a good series for all of you
because it's really not when I say it's
underrated
I mean that I feel the amount of hate
that series gets is undeserving simply
due to its start because I believe the
show has its own space and appeal that a
fair fee of you may actually enjoy and
the series especially the manga has a
lot of merits that anyone who dropped it
after to eardrum bursting episodes after
screams would not be aware of so in
order to defend it I'm probably gonna
have to spoil a bit of it so there will
be minor anime and manga spoilers in
coming I won't go into any major plot
points and I'll try to keep it to the
elements that I found interesting and I
think what I want to start with is the
characters one of the main elements of
any series we look to carry a show is
the cast and characters and when we look
at black clovers characters it's easy to
dismiss them as a group of tropes in
three shades because well they kind of
are on the surface most of the cast
members don't get too much development
say for the main few but for me the
actual strength of the characters don't
come from the individual cast members
but as an ensemble the series is no
problem just throwing a large group of
new characters in your face at once
meaning that you won't get much of an
impression beyond the initial look and
quiet each individual has but the
characters and personalities are varied
enough that is just entertaining to
watch the group dynamic work as a whole
after the arc whereas the fights bad CGI
smack we are properly introduced to the
world of the magic Knights the magic
Knights are split up into different
divisions with each division having a
different personality and group
philosophy led by a captain that
embodies that philosophy on top of this
system most members come from a noble
family but that doesn't necessarily mean
they're in the same division with each
family having their own dynamic and
having rivalries with other big families
and that's not even mentioning the
commoners like Astor and you know add to
this a ranking system that rewards group
and individual performances and you have
a recipe for some entertaining chemistry
what I liked is how the series
spotlights the relationship between the
cast members that hints at these
characters having a long history without
having everything revolve around our
main duo captain poodle head has a
long-standing rivalry with Captain flame
dude captain of the blue rose squad who
has the reputation of being an ice queen
man hater actually has a secret
schoolgirl crush on Yami and I mean how
can you blame her when you're growing up
with this pure perfect specimen
male masculinity please have my babies
yummy little things like this learn a
sense of legitimacy because it feels
like you're watching a huge
dysfunctional group of friends hang out
with each other they banter they take
the piss out of each other but the real
strength is seeing these relationships
grow as the series goes on you see the
general respect for us to change as he
proves himself captain puto head [ __ ]
actually he's shown to have a deep
admiration for his rival and even cares
for him even though everyone serves a
very obvious purpose like even if that
purpose is just add a personality quirk
to the group the series knows this and
it knows the personality cliches that
works and Shonen and it plays to it
Yummie is straight-up an ex shown and
protagonist who has already finished a
series to grow up to become the mentor
character he's designed to be the cool
badass so much so he knows how the
Shonan tropes works because he's been
through all this [ __ ] before he's become
self-aware of it which just makes it
entertaining like if he's ever backed
into a corner he just nonchalantly goes
well I guess it's time to surpass my
limits somehow
no biggie I've done this a million times
before the final Rizzo is that the sum
of the whole ensemble is greater than
any of its individual parts and this
sentiment is something I feel is
mirrored in other aspects of the series
because another big talking point about
black clover has been about its
unoriginal 'ti one of the biggest
criticisms thrown against the series
initially was just how unoriginal
everything was black clovers seem to be
a complete mishmash of different Shonen
tropes and cliches stapled together in
an uninspired way aster seems to be a
melting pot of every shown in
protagonists to ever exist you know
couldn't have been more generic of rival
the world and magic system was basically
a combination of Naruto one piece
bleaching Fairy Tail along with the
premise that hardly had any unique
selling points so you may be wondering
what's changed about this well
surprisingly not much andthat's has
actually turned out to be one of its
biggest strengths black clover continues
to take elements from so many other
series but once you realized that it
just doesn't give a [ __ ] you see that
because of this it can throw in all the
best elements you've seen in other shows
and just plays around with them together
this is as shown in as it gets and it
doesn't try to be anything but vats you
know it's a shounen it knows it's a
shounen so it just gives you this
no-nonsense approach by constantly
drip-feeding you every element it knows
you want to see in a
in a very compact space let's take the
structure of the magic Knights we just
talked about which is essentially just
doing what bleached it with the goat a
13 which I don't really have a problem
with because that was one of my favorite
parts of the soul society arc however it
takes this and adds even more variation
in the personalities and powers of
everyone while also adding in a ranking
system to add a sense of competitiveness
and progression for weaker divisions now
how can we make this even more fun well
let's give a bit of time to develop the
dynamics of each group feed us hints so
we can speculate power levels then put
every division in a massive tournament
arc
oh you wants a magic system here we got
all the magics we got fire ice earth
winds water magic oh you want more we
got metal magic we've got poison magic
we got sparsity or magic we've got
summons we've got paint magic we got
light magic we've got time magic we got
magic that transforms buildings into
giant mecha suits how do these all fit
in a magic system I don't [ __ ] know
who cares you want to see them all
together right well here you go you may
hear this and think well isn't this just
a jack of all trades master of none kind
of bill but I think a better way to
describe is that it is the master at
being a jack-of-all-trades black clover
knows you've already seen on this ship
before so instead of trying to reinvent
the wheel it just keeps throwing you
what you're in a shown in trash wants to
see and has fun with it individually the
elements presented in the series don't
do anything special but it's together
that the series is able to carve its own
identity but there is one big difference
between black clover and the Shonan
titles of old and hell even my hero
academia and that is the pacing
admittedly a lot of the things I talked
about is very surface level one would be
prone to getting old fast and the way
black clover counteracts this is by
never [ __ ] slowing down while
something like my hero academia favors
concrete character building black clover
values constant progression and
escalation and it never ever takes a
break even arcs that seemingly starts
off with an unimportant plot point
almost immediately ramps up to an
incident that steps up in scale to the
previous one logic would normally
dictate that it's impossible to
continually one-up itself each arc
without burning out and digging itself
into a corner but I can say that caught
up to the manga that somehow hasn't
happened yet and we're coming off one of
the most shocking events to happen in
the series thus far this includes the
constant escalation in the power system
which goes against pretty much every
rule I said to my power
escalation video I did
for but it works because in concept
Aster's ability of being able to the
gates of magic is already the most
overpowered ability in the series from
the beginning so no matter how
ridiculous some of the spells become
it's about aster finding a new way to
use his magic cancelling abilities
watching black clover is like eating a
bag of ready salted Walkers crisps
that's potato chip if you're American
ready salted isn't exactly everyone's
favorite flavor but everyone can
appreciate ready salted crisps unless
you're allergic to salt or something and
if that's the case what are you doing in
the anime community but once you open a
Pocky you don't just eat one crisp you
have to at least finish the whole packet
and a single episode or chapter is like
eating a single crisp making the series
so easy to marathon the highs of the
series are definitely less in this
competition but the highs come so often
that you just keep going because it
feels like there's rarely a point where
it's appropriate to stop but of course
all this is pointless if I can't stand
the main character right surely there
could be nothing to redeem this annoying
twerp that makes my ears bleed whenever
he opens his mouth right well aside from
the fact that he does scream less as the
series is going on and if it bothers you
that much you could always watch the dub
there was one moment that actually sold
me on asters character but the anime is
just about to reach this point so
spoiler warning for anime only peeps so
to set the scene we've just finished
asked his biggest fight with the series
thus far and he's badly damaged his arms
to the point where he's broken almost
every bone in them yeah okay shut up
shut up okay but the caveat is that they
you're also cursed to the point where
the curse cannot be removed leaving him
a [ __ ] I said shut up okay
his teammates who find out about this
are distraught for him just when it
seems like everything is going well it
sinks in that the boy with no magic
power cannot even swing his swords
anymore the one thing he can do to get
by in this world and even though he was
acting cheerful to them just a moment
ago as they tried to find him there's
one question on everyone's mind how is
he feeling we see a star sitting alone
the normally loud cheerful boy is
contemplating everything he's just been
told in complete silence and for the
first time since the series started we
see just a glimmer of weakness and
hesitation the thoughts possibly
crossing his minds that this time there
is no coming back
from this and maybe it is time to give
up before I will find a way to heal
these arms you can take that to the bank
or I'll find some other kind of strength
besides my arms and use that to fight
all the way to the end that one time was
the very last time I'm ever gonna get
depressed for real
hasta rejects what he's been told and
have the most shown in fashion possible
tells himself loudly whatever happens he
all find a way to get over this hurdle
this little moment changed so much of
the way I think of asters character
the reason for his shouting the reason
for his obnoxious attitude his seemingly
overconfidence isn't because he's just
an annoying loud little brat he was born
in a world where he was doomed to fail
and has constantly been told that so he
works he worked as hard as he could his
entire life to prove everyone wrong
even if deep inside he's scared that
they're right him shouting this to
himself shows that he's not just
shouting for people to listen to him
he's shouting as much so he listens to
himself he plays the character he wishes
to be says the words he wants to hear
because anything is better than sinking
back into a state where he gives in to
what everyone's been telling him and
that was something I was not expecting
when I first started watching this show
of course we all wish it was this easy
to get over our biggest hurdles in life
but this is Shonen this is the reason we
watch a show like this and in these few
short panels black clover turned aster
from a loud annoying cliche to someone
with an admirable attitude someone who
keeps his ideals wait wrong show and
that's kind of where I stand with black
clover my main complaints right now
aren't with most of the problems that
the series started with but it's more
with the anime adaptation itself the
beginning of the anime takes away one of
the biggest strengths of the manga it's
pacing and it doesn't really start to
pick up until about episode 17 which in
modern anime is a death sentence but
more than that now it's the animation
inconsistency as later episodes fix the
pacing issue the consistency in the
animation varies greatly with some of
the best and worse
animated episodes literally coming out
back-to-back when it's good it's [ __ ]
fantastic but when it's bad it really
takes away to some of the impacts the
manga had the adaptation is going down
the roots of continually releasing an
episode every week rather than the
modern approach of releasing a season
every year which not only allows the
manga to get ahead but also allows for a
better production schedule to produce
more focus and concise episodes simply
put the black clover animes a 2003
Shonen anime adaptation in 2018 and
that's why if you do want to experience
black clover unless you have very
adverse to reading my recommendation
would be to read the manga and re-watch
some of the best flights in the anime
because really if black clover was
released in that time period I honestly
believe it would have stood up with your
big three it's a series that takes so
much inspiration from the shonan's of
those times but even today I still think
it has its own charm it is a series made
for shown in trash [ __ ] boys like me and
doesn't give a [ __ ] about pleasing
anyone else if you're not too shown and
fan this series is not gonna change your
minds but the reason I wanted to make
this video isn't to say that everyone
should go out to watch all these black
clover now it's because we memes the
[ __ ] out of it at the beginning because
it was so [ __ ] me mobile but I think
it's done enough to prove that has its
own merits and if you're shown it in
trash like me especially if you grew up
with the early 2000s shonan's of the big
three and have a free weekend you will
absolutely blast through this it's a
ridiculously marathon of all series that
despite its god-awful start and premise
serves you up for no [ __ ] approach
of pure battle shown and goodness
without any of the feeling it is still
the problem child of Shonen that doesn't
shine as brightly as its peers but you
know what I can't help but enjoy it
straightforward direct demeanor that
gives me everything my inner Shonen
trash once so you can keep on screaming
as loud as you want black clover I will
still eat it all up
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed the video
thank you against a nice protocol for
sponsoring this video they came to me
ever live we really want to work for you
dad and I was like I'm ready work you in
a black favorite video right now and hey
what like you know so if any of what I
talked about the bacon fest tube you
could download the game when iOS or I
enjoy to the link below also thank you
very much to Robert hardcore Basile
Patrick Madsen valve cap and everyone
else on my patron lb this month if you
missed it last week and I didn't also do
a stream of all my reactions to all the
new out of a coming out this season it
was actually a scalable I'll fudge is
weaving out with 2,000 different people
on the stream so I'm definitely gonna do
the skin for next season and who knows
this might be a regular thing currently
the VOD s are still up my twitter and
twitch.tv slash bigger but I might also
up like the one wintry one still don't
know what I'm gonna hear with them
whether my second channel on this
channel I don't know yeah but anyway
that's all for me today in those further
updates I people jingle and I will see
you all next time